let me move on to the five ways that
you can create proper wealth when i say
proper wealth i'm talking
minimum seven figures okay like we're
talking a million dollars plus okay
and even that isn't a lot of money in
today's world i was talking to some guys
in the sauna the other day at the gym
and housing where i live right now a
million dollars will get you a townhouse
okay
um housing where i live they're two
million dollar houses plus
you're not going to get much for a
million dollars like you're not really
rich anymore if you have a million bucks
here in the gta anywhere you know like
in toronto um you need five to ten
million dollars to be properly sorted
out minimum i would say
so
the professions that can get you to that
let's go through them one by one is a
professional
and we're talking lawyer doctor surgeon
engineer
something like that
not
based professional like you're a school
teacher or a professor at a university
you're not going to make that kind of
i'm talking about proper professional
lawyer doctor surgeon um you know stuff
like that and in some countries you get
paid more than others like if you're a
doctor or if you're a brain surgeon in
canada you're going to make a lot less
than a brain surgeon in the united
states for example but generally
speaking if you pursue a career like
that you pay off your student loan debt
or if you get a grant whatever you can
do quite well in life
you're going to work crazy hours
you're going to take a lot of [ __ ]
you're going to be part i mean you know
part of
some of these jobs over here is that
kind of suck now today because of all
the wokeness that's infused into a lot
of these professions the next one number
two
you know to create uh serious wealth
c-suite jobs
ceo cto coo you know chief executive
something chief technology officer chief
financial officer um
guys like this either come from running
businesses themselves and having
successful exits or they work their way
up the corporate ladder
okay and again
some of these things there's not a lot
of these jobs you know some guys be like
oh rich's head's in the clouds there's
not a lot of these jobs for people okay
fine be poor i don't give a [ __ ] it
doesn't matter to me if you want to
exclude yourself from being successful
and making the money and creating the
wealth and you know these these kids
that are constantly approaching going
like i want those cars what do you guys
do for a living sort of thing if you
want that [ __ ] you have work to do i'm
just telling you i don't care if you
don't do it or not doesn't bother me
uh number three high ticket sales
you're selling private jets yachts
expensive cars rolls royce uh you know
koenigsegg bugatti stuff like that right
high ticket sales
real estate you know if you're selling
20 20 million dollar mansions like when
you're selling high ticket items you're
getting a percentage of that high ticket
item
it varies from industry to industry but
you can make some serious money
i know some guys that are in yacht sales
that do very very well um you know it's
not uncommon for
a boat to cost 20 30 40 50 100 million
200 million a billion like you know like
you can get up there you know really the
sky's the limit when it comes to
building
high-end stuff and believe it or not
there's a lot of very [ __ ] rich
people out there um that even if they
tried to spend their money in their
lifetime they would have a very very
difficult time doing it so um you know
they deploy it on things that they like
if they like yachting they'll buy a
yacht if they like you know if something
like
a private jet saves them travel they'll
buy a private jet you know
and don't confuse somebody that owns a
private jet with people that just like
lease them for a flight very different
thing
um
number four
basically being influential i put
influencer in this category but in the
past it would have been actor musician
something like that like you have an
audience
you know you're a rock star you're a
popular actor but included in that
category today which i mean i want to
say is
basically permissionless
you don't need anybody's permission to
be an influencer like these like there's
influencers on social media with
millions of followers
and they're just chicks that hold up
energy drinks bang energy drinks some
other [ __ ] or whatever but they work on
their body and they look good and
they've got nice outfits and they have a
tan and a good photographer and blah
blah blah sort of thing but um you know
influencers if you're a woman is very
easy it's well i'm not going to say
varies but but it's easier than being a
successful influencer with an audience
than it is being a man a guy's got to do
different things we just can't bust out
our tits and ass and you know get people
to follow us right like we have to we
have to say and do things that um are
useful right women on the other hand
they just have to look pretty
some of them look pretty and say useful
things less of them say useful things
and don't and don't look pretty but the
point that i'm making number four on
this list of items where you can um you
know you can chase these things down and
make serious money is basically having
an audience actors have an audience
musicians have an audience and you know
the social media influencers today have
an audience some people would argue that
i'm an influencer but you know you get
the idea
yeah i see most in a chatty saying i got
called an influencer today very funny
and look you know um if if if people
rely on you if they look to you for
advice um
you know for help with whatever it is
they're stuck on they're gonna call you
whatever they want but you won't make
serious money
unless you have a large audience
i'm going to say minimum a million on
tick tock or instagram
youtube is a different game you can
start to make some serious money on
youtube after a hundred thousand quarter
million i mean i even know some people
within a hundred thousand subs that are
that are doing quite well um because
they figured out how to monetize their
audience properly uh but anyway having
reach in influences is definitely number
four and the last and final one which
happens to be my favorite which i've
used to create my own wealth is
entrepreneurship
um
i will say this uh here let me grab this
over here because i'm [ __ ] behind the
ball for some reason i thought i had
this ready on my screen but my uh
school of entrepreneurship course is
opening later on this month um it's not
open right now but
i might as well mention it and i'll drop
the link in the chat if you're on my
email list you're you're already gonna
get the uh notification when it opens up
for enrollment but it'll be in a couple
weeks time um so get on the
email
wait
list
here
and
the whole point of the course guys is
that it it removes the mystery the fog
of war when it comes to
um
what the best entrepreneurs do to make
serious money there's two kinds of
businesses i'll explain in another video
closer to when the course launches
health businesses and half business
basically there's businesses that are
easy to run that make a lot of money and
there's businesses that are harder to
run that don't make as much money will
frustrate the [ __ ] out of you most
people choose a ladder the vast majority
of guys that will say oh i want to
choose a path to wealth under
entrepreneurship write my own check have
freedom whatever the narrative is going
in their head they'll say i'll go start
up a business but then they go and start
up a kind of business that doesn't
create money freedom happiness and um
doesn't create havoc in their life you
know kind of like like the chicks with
the red flags sort of thing it's the
equivalent of dating a chick with red
flags is what most guys do when they
start a business so the whole point of
the course is i've taken everything that
i've learned over the years
washed away the fluff and the [ __ ]
and i've said look this is what the most
successful entrepreneurs do when it
comes to selecting a business dealing
with
like many of the challenges that arise
in a business where it comes to human
resources accounting regulations uh
insurance taxes all that sort of stuff i
did a survey like six seven months ago
and i asked a bunch of people what they
wanted to see in the course and that's
what went in it i've started to add some
new modules
um there's currently
i think three extra ones right now i've
got to add a fourth this week the extra
one that i'm going to add is is going to
be telling you exactly how to build an
audience i'm going to tell you exactly
how i build an audience on youtube um
because number four is basically being
an influencer so the same rules will
apply to writing a blog um
other social media platforms like tick
tock and instagram twitter all that sort
of stuff so i'll get into those details
later um let me just see what's here in
the chat before i um
drop the link for you guys to let me
grab the link actually i'll do it right
now copied
okay so i'm gonna put this link on um
the youtube live stream
uh on the unplugged alpha if you guys
are listening to the
audio or you're like on a podcast or if
you're watching it somewhere else later
as a replay you should have been on
youtube
uh
come in and ask
any question
loma so there's a stream yard link there
make sure you have a good connection
um and be respectful of my time and the
other people waiting because there's
often quite a few people to try to get
through
uh all right what do we got here so we
got a couple of new members thanks for
joining supporting the channel in the
live chat awesome to see people
greg says what's the true definition of
a millionaire is it liquid or assets
after debt value look
um
usually when they weigh somebody's
wealth out and they say you're a
millionaire they basically take their
net worth right so they take a look at
their assets so housing investments all
that sort of stuff you can slice and
dice it different ways right i mean like
to place a value on a bit like for
example let's use twitter and elon musk
right so
twitter comes along
when elon musk makes the offer to buy
and they say we want 44 billion or some
[ __ ] like that okay
they start talking back and forth and
then it comes to his attention that a
lot of the users are potentially
fraudulent bots or um you know like sock
puppet accounts for people one of the
things you'll notice on twitter if you
use it is that there's a lot of people
that don't use their main account they
use these fake sock puppet accounts
because all they do is they go on and
they [ __ ] blow out you know in the
comments and they try to create havoc
because they're losers they got nothing
else better through their time you know
which is again why i don't read comments
on [ __ ] twitter and stuff like that
so because of the bots and the sock
puppet accounts they came to realize
well a lot of the accounts look like
they're fake so it doesn't look like
it's worth 44 billion because he's
basically buying a user base he's buying
the attention of people so he's like
well let's let's get to the bottom of
this and make an offer that's based on
what the real users are and the whole
[ __ ] thing falls apart so the value
of somebody's wealth can
really go up and down it can move around
a lot depending on how you value and
establish businesses which is how most
people determine their net worth if that
makes sense
um
evening
greg oh uh please define the definition
of being a mailer for the subscribers is
it net worth in the moment is it assets
outside of yeah so
same question i guess you just did a
super chat to get my attention but yeah
same thing it's it's your assets right
as they're valued and again the value
can go up and down like
um
like i would put the mclaren in my net
worth uh 285 might have been the
purchase price but in the last year and
a half the prices have gone up it's
worth 350. so it really depends on when
you price things it really depends on
when you price a business you know
how they're going to price a business
there's different metrics but yeah so it
can go up and down a little bit hey guys
i really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forge
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you